فنتابع ابرز التطورات من داخل سوريا من
شمال سوريا ينضم الينا صهيب الخلف ونتحدث
عنه مع العنوان ربما الرئيسي اليوم في
نشراتنا وهذا الخطر الذي يتهدد المركوبين
في تلك المناطق بسبب احتمال
تاثر سد التلول
بالزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه مؤخرا اليك
الكلمه صهيب
نعم وصلنا اخيرا الى الفتحه التي حدثت في
السد الترابي الذي اقامه المزارعون هنا
بالتعاون مع وزاره الزراعه لكي يفصل
مياهها نهر العاصي عن قريتهم لكن اثار
الزلزال اسفرت عن فيضان نهر العاصي وهذا
الامر شكل ضغطا كبيرا
نعم كنت اتحدث عن ان مياه نهر العاصي فاضت
وشكلت ضغطا على السد الترابي الذي اقيم في
وجه مياه النهر وليشكل حائلا بينها وبين
بيوت القريه وبساتينها لكن الضغط الكبير
عليه ادى الى انفجاره
وتدمير جزء منه هذا الجزء سمح للمياه
بالدخول الى بساتين القريه ومن ثم الى
بيوتها نزحا عدد كبير من سكان القريه
باتجاه المناطق الاعلى نسبيا الان تظهر
بصوره الجزء الذي دمر من هذا الساتر ومن
هذا السد الترابي طبعا هنا مياه نهر
العاصي تدخل بعد قرابه 500 متر فقط الى
الاراضي التركيه ويظهر علينا كذلك
الجدار الاسمنتي الذي اقيم بين الحدود
السوريه والتركيه سنحاول ان نصل له
بالكاميرا ولكن بطبيعه الحال هنا
نعاني من قله او ضعف الاشاره بشكل كبير